okay you're almost ready oh wait i'm
almost ready okay um there you go okay
ready
and the zombie mobile
three two
one oh one baby boy i almost want work
mine didn't work i i need a do-over
all right three two one
it didn't work again well you know
that's okay zoe oh zoe can play with
almost there elmo's that works great
well thanks elbow
oh boy
i guess i'm just no good at building
ramps i'm sorry oh hi elmo hi zoe hi mr
spell
what's wrong zoe oh my ramp doesn't work
i'm just gonna go play with elmo's rail
oh hold on a second any great
engineering project is going to involve
some trial and error it's not that your
ramp doesn't work it's just that it
doesn't work yet that's the power of yet
oh mr sam is that like a superpower kind
of elmo it's a superpower that we all
have it's the idea that mistakes aren't
bad and that we learn from them so we
keep trying
but i tried my ramp twice already well
what did you try differently the second
time well nothing well why don't we look
closer and see if we can try a different
approach and even if that doesn't work
it's okay we'll learn from it
okay well the zoe mobile crashed right
here yeah so
maybe i need to just
fill this hole that's a good idea oh i
think i have a block that'll do just the
trick oh wait
there you go zoe i like the way you're
thinking like the great engineer that
you are ah all right here let me try
okay come here zoe mobile
here we go
oh no
oh that's it i'm just giving up no no no
no no not if you believe in the power of
yet
you know how your your muscles get
stronger when you exercise oh yeah i'm
super strong watch this
exactly making mistakes and coming up
with solutions to solve your problems is
exercise for your brain
it's brainer size
right when you believe you can do it and
you keep trying that's when your brain
is growing and you're learning new
things wow it's called a growth mindset
ah okay
well then i'm gonna try again that's
okay zoe
that time the zoe mobile crashed right
here right so maybe if i get rid of this
block
hey look at that nice straight line all
the way down
but that'll do it here let me try okay
come here zoe mobile
here we
go
good job zoey oh boy the joy mobile one
circle thing
can zoey make elmo's ramp taller and
faster too let's do it together
great job guys i'm so proud that you
kept trying you weren't afraid to make
mistakes and because of it we all
learned a ton yeah
and that's the power of yes
come on zoey let's play all right okay
so maybe if there's like something here